aber wie geht das eigentlich schwangeren
in den zeiten von corona darüber möchte
ich jetzt sprechen mit hebammen janine
wilna frau will ja vielleicht können sie
uns etwas dazu sagen wie ist es denn
gerade schwanger zu sein in diesen
zeiten müssen schwangere wirklich angst
haben vielleicht können sie konkrete
tipps geben was die schwangere jetzt tun
können also sehr groß und es werden
viele tränen mittlerweile auch per handy
getrocknet wir hebammen sind ja generell
die ansprechpartnerinnen für
schwangerschaft geburt und die zeit
danach und haben sehr engen kontakt mit
den frauen und das erschwert uns auch
gerade dass wir eben nicht einfach die
frauen in den arm nehmen können und auch
körperlich nahe sein können
wir versuchen natürlich alles was geht
ihnen ängste zu nehmen
wir versuchen auch uns zu schützen weil
auch gehe ja nicht wissen wer ist
infiziert wo können wir uns infizieren
und ich denke das wichtigste ist einfach
dass wir jetzt da sind für die
schwangeren dass wir ihnen sicherheit
bieten dass wir sie gut betreuen
und ja dass wir einfach da sind und dazu
zählt auch immer noch die häuslichen
hausbesuche die vorsorge bei der hebamme
gerade vielleicht jetzt keine
wartezimmer wirklich eins zu eins um so
eben gut für sie da sein zu können
konkrete tipps an die schwangeren die
jetzt eben sorgen haben was sollen wir
jetzt machen also ganz kontakt mit ihrer
hebamme aufzunehmen
die ängste auszusprechen dass wir
einfach gemeinsam schauen können was
können wir gezielt tun viele haben angst
dass ihre hebamme nicht mehr nach hause
kommt viele kolleginnen können auch kein
online kurs anbieten
also auch da vielleicht nachfragen bei
anderen kolleginnen dass man sich im
innen live kurs mit rein kommt um eben
dort auch gezielt tipps zu bekommen wie
kann ich mich auf eine geburt
vorbereiten wie ist das wenn das baby
geboren ist einfach wirklich auch
praktische tipps natürlich bespreche ich
auch mit den ganz klar wie man richtig
hände wäscht das eben der besuch im
wochenbett also nach der geburt jetzt
erst mal flach fällt die frauen dürfen
auch keinen besuch mehr auf der
wochenbett station bekommen
daher habe ich im moment viele anfragen
zum thema hausgeburt und da muss man
einfach ganz deutlich sagen wir hebammen
sind die letzten jahre immer hinten
runtergefallen wir wurden verheizt
wir sind nicht systemrelevant dabei
helfen wir neuem leben auf die welt und
viele hebammen haben ihren beruf
aufgegeben
und es gibt nicht genug haus geboten die
jetzt eben haus geburtshilfe anbieten
könnten
wir haben auch große sorgen muss ich
auch sagen was ist wenn im kreißsaal
eine hebamme positiv getestet wird
die kreißsäle sind schlecht besetzt
regions- weise also für manche kliniken
für manche kreißsäle würde eine corona
infektion der hebamme bedeuten dass der
kreis er ganz schließen muss und da bin
ich ganz klar bei den frauen dass ich
sage wir müssen uns gut schützen wir
müssen einfach abstand halten
wir müssen dafür sorgen dass alle zu
hause bleiben die nicht unbedingt
draußen unterwegs sein müssen
sie haben gerade ihre sorgen schon
angesprochen
das heißt sie könnten nicht ausreichend
schützen ich habe gehört da gibt es aber
schon kreative lösungen vielleicht
könnte uns das mal zeigen und auch
erzählen ja also wir warum hebammen team
babenhausen meine praxis wir sind ganz
glücklich wir haben nämlich drei tolle
näherinnen und im moment nicht jana im
akku
für uns wir haben solche masten genäht
bekommen
ich möchte sich das gut sehen kann
einfach auf doppel lagen stoff extra
auch mit einer bibel vorrichtung dass es
wirklich eng anliegend ist denn das
problem ist wir werden alleine gelassen
wir heben wir kriegen keine info von
unserem gesundheitsamt wir kommen nicht
mehr an masten die handschuhe werden
knapp das studium wird knapp und nur so
können wir eben auch die hausbesuche
weiterhin machen und auch bei den
geburten muss man einfach auch sagen
auch die kliniken haben immer weniger
material und die hebammen kreisen und
auch die gynäkologen auch ganz wichtig
auch die gynäkologen werden dabei
vergessen dann vielen dank für ihre
schilderungen wir hoffen dass die
situation nicht noch weiter
verschlimmert und jetzt wollen wir noch
mal die sorgen einer schweren direkt
hören von julien aus wuppertal
naja eigentlich war geplant dass meine
mama mit
okay zum kaiserschnitt kommt und oben im
kreißsaal meine schwester wartet ja und
da das alles gar nicht mehr so möglich
ist sonst ja besucher im krankenhaus
nicht mehr lauf sind und so wie es auch
echt jetzt aussieht keine
begleitpersonen bis auch nicht der vater
der mit im haushalt lebt hat durch das
besuchsverbot werde ich wahrscheinlich
allein im krankenhaus seien kein besuch
erhalten
[Musik]
ja und der plan ist halt durch video
chats kann doch irgendwie die kleine zu
zeigen dass es uns gut geht dann wünsche
ich mir aber auch dass ja alles abflacht
und man doch zusammen zusammen sein kann
der familie und sich über die kleine
freuen können ja besondere umstände also
gerade für alle werdenden mütter